oh okay I was gonna say about this this
show years ago where I played this
character Skeeter the junkie and and my
partner in the scene was undercover cop
who I didn't know was undercover cop so
when I finally realized and he finally
lets me know he's a cop and I've given
him the information he wants he's
supposed to throated a little bag of you
know dope you know which I had you know
give me the dope when I taste all right
he's gonna just throw it down and I'm
supposed to pick it up and do that whole
thing you know and so the guy that
played the scene with me he got into it
so so crazy cuz he had his family they
had everything you know he was like all
in then he threw the dope off the stage
I mean literally threw it off the stage
and he's like oh no he just looked like
this and I looked in saw it and did the
same I had to have the dope so in the
audience he threw it right in the front
row by some like some ladies who's
sitting there by her leg and she's like
looking down like this and the audience
everybody looking and everybody's like
and I and I felt everybody looking like
what AM what am I got what is he gonna
do I calmly stayed in character kept
saying a line and you know whatever as
dumb as a junkie walked off the stage
went down there by that lady's foot
grabbed the dope
walk back up on the stage and finish the
scene and when we left the stage at the
end of that scene they they just went
crazy because it was like what am I
gonna do I got to play the scene and
this is real so the my dope is over
there so I couldn't just act like okay
I'm a lot of dope is down there so let
me act like in mind that I really have
it no no no no no I went down there
walked off that stage and went down and
picked that dope upset my lines some of
them down there and came up to here I
gave you
I'm gonna get ready and I put the little
thing around my arm went back up on
stage did that took my yeah I mean the
sing was over basically after that but
the audience is like whoa because I
didn't let it throw me to the point
where I was like because I was always I
was locked into the character even
though I'm locked in I know that okay I
got to get this dope cuz that's what my
thing was I that's that's what I had to
have in that scene that's what I had I
had to have it I got to get this dope I
got to get this dope for me that was the
driving force of me in that scene they
get that don't cuz I got to shoot up I
gave him what he wanted so for me not to
go down and get that dope would have
been really just looting it was like
okay and it'll show curtain I've been in
shows where we do we would do two seen
similar almost like a flashback in a
show and a guy was in the show who came
in he had been high on some stuff hmm
and we had two similar scenes where the
guys are sitting around playing cards
and the other people backstage had had
different costuming for the two
different scenes when they come out he
skipped the first scene of us playing
cards and went to the second see oh and
all the actors on stage in the scene
with him tried to get him back we
started rewriting and getting back to
what he was supposed to say in the first
scene he wouldn't do it so the people
behind and we out there performing now I
mean that's when you kind of like okay
it's hard for me to stay in this now
because we got to save this and save him
and he's sitting there looking around
like this spaced out and you could hear
all the other actors backstage
scrambling to get a costume so me and
one of the other guys had lived some
stuff and I kind of casually look over
like this and the the one of the actors
gave me the sound like okay we ready and
then we went right to the next scene
then of course he's high
at the end of the night the director in
the stage manager to come out what the
hell happened
he says they messed escena and we like
what he says you said this I said no you
read the second scene he said no no I
said get the book get the script so he
got the script I said you said this
right here and I said this he said yeah
I said that's the second scene he's like
and I told him when we left that night I
gave him a ride I said they don't know
you like I know you leave those drugs
alone if you do that again I'm gonna
slap you out there I say you can't be
coming into your high like that I mean I
did two at one time I did a show one
time where I had smoked some stuffs weed
and perform it and I said never in my
life again will I do that again not only
for me but for these other actors and
mistreat them like that I said that that
was the worst thing I was so ashamed of
myself and I didn't really screw nothing
up but I wasn't all in and that wasn't
fair to these other people that wasn't
fair to the audience that wasn't fair to
anybody and I said why would I do that
cuz I thought I was being cute oh yeah
you know